thank you to skillshare for supporting
this episode of journey to the micro
cosmos
if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description
you can get a two-month free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
[Music]
as we observe the world around us what
we see is shaped
by the way our eyes process the light
that's bouncing and absorbing and
passing
through our surroundings for many of us
what this means is that when we look at
this clip of cyanobacteria we see
green strips sliding along a blue
background
for others depending on their eyes and
any other corrective measures the colors
may be different or the edges blurred
or the image may not exist at all the
final product
will come down to the physical and
chemical reactions
that are taking place in our eyes in
response
to light and how that informs the
biological processing
that comes next microbes
don't have this sort of complex visual
processing but many still
need to know where the light around them
is whether that's to seek out food or
avoid hidden dangers
they may not see things the way we do
but the mechanisms they have in place
allow them to respond to light in
extraordinary ways
to meet the most ordinary of needs
perhaps the most primitive of these
methods are
light-sensitive pigments called
phytochromes
but when we say primitive we don't mean
to diminish their importance
or their complexity if whole ecosystems
are built on photosynthesis then
phytochromes
are essential to life as it currently
exists
scientists first discovered phytochromes
in plants
where they helped answer long-standing
questions about how plants respond to
seasonal changes in light
but the ancestors of those plant
pigments are found in cyanobacteria
like acelatoria whose phytochromes help
regulate growth movement and
photosynthesis
these phytochromes respond not just to
the amount of light but
also the color of it and remarkably
cyanobacteria phytochromes can respond
to a wider range of colors
than plant phytochromes which makes
sense if we think about where
cyanobacteria live they live
in water because of how
water absorbs light there's usually
more red light at the surface and then
more
green and blue light the deeper you go
if a cyanobacteria
were to have a pigment that detects only
red light
or only blue light it would end up
restricted in where it could live
so instead these simple little organisms
perform
a complex calculation called chromatic
adaptation calibrating the amount of
their various
pigments so they can maximize how much
light they're getting from their
environment
but cyanobacteria are unicellular
organisms that
want light what about those that don't
both blepharism and stinter corulius
are well known for their photophobic
nature
the reaction is straightforward when
confronted with light
these microbes start backpedaling
this response is set off when light
interacts with their pigments
the pink blepharisman in the blepharisma
and the blue stenterin
in center corulius these pigments are
used as a toxin
against predators but they can make
their own organisms sensitive to light
to a dangerous degree providing
excellent motivation to avoid
sad light and these photophobic
responses
may also help the blepharisma and
stunters
avoid predators with better vision than
their own
these photosensitive pigments are like
nature's way
of unlocking the foundations of vision
they are not themselves a specialized
structure
to see an example of a specialized
structure
let's look at that bright red eye spot
on the euglena
also called a stigma the eye spot
is not actually an eye it's more like
a sunglass for the true photoreceptor
that structure is located close to the
euglena's flagella
and it's made up of around 50 layers
of stacked membranes that hold hexagonal
arrangements of
roughly a million photoreceptor proteins
the stigma shades the photoreceptor
but just on one side of the euglena
and as the microbe rotates and different
wavelengths of light
filter through and then get shaded by
the stigma
the euglena is actually getting
information on
where it can find light
as we shift from unicellular to
multicellular organisms
we start to see what microscopic eyes
look like one of the important
evolutionary developments was the
formation of a cup
shape in these eye-like structures which
helps provide
spatial information
some of these animal eyes are mysterious
like those
meaty little buttons atop many a
tardigrade's heads
sure scientists have documented that
many tardigrade species
have what they call inverse pigmented
eye cups
but what do they see well we do not know
others like the planarian have a
pigmented eye cup connected to
photoreceptor cells which actually
provides
enough similarities to our own eyes
to make them useful for medical studies
and as the animals get larger so does
their potential for complex visual
systems
similar to many insects daphnia have
compound eyes that are made up of units
called
amatidia which focus light onto
photoreceptor cells
to form images the larger the
eye the more information the daphnia and
other animals with these kinds of
image-forming eyes can get
but size and complexity come with
trade-offs
sure these eyes help the animal navigate
and find
food but these are costly organs to
build and maintain
one study found that the retina in a
blowfly's eye
took up 10 percent of its resting
metabolic rate
eyes and these analogous structures have
evolved in response to what we
need to process from our surroundings
needs inform evolution which in turn
informs new needs and light can provide
for those
needs but it can also pose its own
dangers
in the origin of species charles darwin
famously describes the eye as an
organ of extreme perfection
he introduces it as an example of
biological complexity that may at first
pose some consternation to those
considering natural selection
after all how could something so
remarkable
be made through iterations and
iterations of
tiny gradual changes but in darwin's
search through natural history
the case for stacking gradual change
upon gradual change seems less
improbable
and science has continued to support
this theory
with that said it's tempted to get
caught up in this story that has been
cultivated over eons and related
entirely to the structures that make up
our own eyes that was our entry point
into this discussion after all but one
of the most
remarkable aspects of evolution is the
understanding
that it is not something that was
leading
to us evolution has led
to a whole world all of these remarkable
structures and chemicals have their own
unique
properties that suit the organisms
they reside in allowing creatures that
yes may be simpler than ourselves
to use systems that are not just
good enough for their survival they are
ideal for their survival these organisms
are thus able to survive in ways
that you and i could never be capable of
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
if you'd like to learn more about using
your eyes to observe the world around
you
in different ways skillshare has you
covered
thanks to classes like frame a great
shot exploring photo composition you can
learn how to better take
photos whether you're shooting with your
cell phone camera
or a dslr photographer porter yates will
walk you through the process of finding
the right environment
choosing your subject and i'll also
share some insights and tips
about what makes a good compelling
photograph
skillshare is an online learning
community that
offers membership with meaning with so
much to explore
real-world projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
and it makes it easy with short classes
that will fit
into your daily routine a premium
membership will give you unlimited
access
so you can join classes and communities
that are right for you
an annual subscription to skillshare is
less than ten dollars a month and if
you're one of the first thousand people
to click the link in the description
you can get a two-month free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
and thank you of course also to all of
the people whose names are on the screen
right now
these are the people who make this
channel possible
so if you like it you have them to thank
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby